[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Hello,
everyone, and welcome.
I'm Filippo, and I work
on the Go team at Google.
It's the team that maintenance
the Go programming language.
And today, I'm joined by
three of my colleagues
to answer questions collected
both before the show
and during the live AMA.
if you registered for the
event and reserved your spot,
you will see a Q&A button on the
right-hand side of the video.
So please, do follow up on
our answers and questions,
and we'll try to
pick out what we can.
Now, myself, I'm the lead
of the security team,
and the security
team is in charge
of making sure that Go is a tool
to build secure applications.
So not just making sure
that Go is secure itself--
which is part of our job--
but also making sure that
you can use Go security
and safely to build secure
applications yourself
and keep your application safe.
KATIE HOCKMAN: Hi, I'm Katie.
I actually work with Filippo
on the Go security team
over in New York City.
I came to the security
team after being
a tech lead of the Go
module mirror and checksum
database, which are tools that
can help you download Go source
code in a way that's a lot more
secure and a lot more reliable.
Nowadays, I've been working
on adding a native fuzzing
to Go with my team, and that's
a form of automated testing
that can help find edge case
bugs that your unit tests might
miss.
JULIE QIU: Hi, I'm Julie.
I'm the tech lead of the Go
web team, which works primarily
on the Go package discovery
site that lives at pkg.go.dev.
So the Go package
discovery site is a place
that helps Go developers find
packages that might help them
in developing
their own projects,
and then also give
them the information
that they need to
evaluate and decide
if they want to use these
packages in their projects.
REBECCA STAMBLER: Hey, everyone.
I'm Rebecca, and I work
on Go's developer tooling.
So the Go team actually
supports a backend
that provides IDE-like
features to most major editors,
like VSCode, Vim,
Emacs, and Sublime,
and we also maintain the
go plug-in for VSCode.
So I'll be talking about how
these developer tools can
help you write secure Go code.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Excellent.
So we're going to start with
a question about software use.
It's 2021, and
whatever you're doing,
you're always using software.
Now, Rebecca how does Go
provide dependency management?
REBECCA STAMBLER: So
Go code is typically
grouped into packages,
and then related packages
can be grouped into
a larger module.
And so a module is
basically the unit
of dependency management in Go.
What happens is you
can import libraries
that are provided by different
modules into your own module.
And the way that you do that
is by having a go.mod file
at the root of your project.
And that go.mod
file will specify
each module that you
require and its version
that you require that.
So that way, you'll
get reproducible builds
in your projects.
And actually, it's really simple
to get started with Go modules.
All you really need to
do is run a command,
just go mod init
inside of a directory,
and it will create this
go.mod file for you.
And then, the go
command will allow
you to download, and
upgrade, and downgrade
your different dependencies.
And also, you can also get
this feature for your editor,
so you can manage your
modules through your editor,
and you don't ever
have to actually
manually edit that go.mod file.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Excellent.
You mentioned reproducible
results, and that is definitely
something that is dear to the
heart of the security team,
because that means
that even if something
changes in the outside
world, a build of a Go module
will always be the
same, independent,
and there's no way for
external compromises
to influence the
application after its Go has
become reproducible.
Now, we talked about how
the modules are managed,
but the next question,
I think, is for Julie.
How do I choose
dependencies for my project?
JULIE QIU: Yeah, that's
a really great question.
And I mentioned that my team
works primarily on the Go
package discovery site.
And it was actually
built for the purpose
of helping developers choose
their third party dependencies.
So as we were
building the site, I
would say that we thought about
surfing [INAUDIBLE] information
that belonged to
three main categories.
And I would break these down
into popularity, quality,
and stability.
So a little bit about each one.
Popularity, I think, is
important because it really
just acts as a social signal.
It tells you other people
are using this package.
They've probably already
done the work for you
to evaluate whether or not
this package is dependable.
And if the author of
the package decides
that they want to stop
maintaining the project,
it's likely that one
of the many people who
are depending on this project
might step up and continue
to maintain it.
When I say "quality,"
quality really
just means looking at the
quality of the code itself.
Is this project well-documented?
Is it well-tested?
And does it generally just
look like quality Go code
that you feel comfortable
including in your own project?
And I think lastly, stability.
That's the topic that's probably
the most dear to the security
team's heart.
It means figuring out whether
or not this package is reliable.
So security vulnerabilities
is definitely
one of those features.
You want to look at
a package and see,
does it have a history of
security vulnerabilities?
But in general, you're just
really looking at the package
to see, is this something
that I can not only
depend on today, but months
from now or years from now,
and looking at conventions, like
Rebecca mentioned, with Go Mod
Tools, whether or not the author
follows semantic versioning,
those are all some
things you want to look
at when considering stability.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Excellent.
Now, the next
question, I feel like,
is definitely for me and Katie.
What are some new things
coming to Go that will
help with end-to-end security?
One thing that I want
to mention myself
is that we are building a
solution for vulnerability
patching in Go.
So what we want to handle
is when there are already
vulnerabilities that are
known in the outside world,
we want to make
sure that you can
get to know when those
vulnerabilities affect
your application or any
of its dependencies.
So there are two pieces to this.
One is that we're
going to maintain
a first-party vulnerability
database, where we track
and collect all
vulnerabilities that
have been disclosed publicly
in any Go module that's
publicly importable.
And then, we'll provide tooling,
tentatively called a Go audit,
that will use the database,
access the database,
and then report which
of the vulnerabilities
that are known affect
your application.
What's interesting
about it is that it's
going to use static analysis
to make sure that it only
shows you the ones
that are actually
relevant to your application.
So even if you do depend on a
version of a dependency that
has a vulnerability, if there
is no way for your application
to reach that code-- maybe
because you're not using that
mode, or plugin, or setting--
the code, it will not
tell you about it,
so that when you
get a report, you
know that you can
prioritize fixing it
and spend the time to figure
out what it is and why.
And Katie, do you want
to talk about fuzzing?
KATIE HOCKMAN: Yeah,
I would love to.
Fuzzing is something that's
very near and dear to my heart.
I'm really excited about
this coming really soon.
Fuzzing is-- like
I said before, it's
a kind of automated
testing that's
a little bit different
from unit tests,
and it's something
that, in the past,
has often really
just been leveraged
by security researchers.
And while that's
really great, we
think that every developer
who wants to use this tool
can benefit from it.
It can help find bugs that
your unit tests might miss.
And how it can do that is
in its kind of fuzzing mode,
it actually can run
a fuzzing engine,
which generates inputs for you.
It can do some
really smart things
to try to find new coverage
and find new crashes.
And in the default
mode, it's going
to work a lot like a
unit test will, where
you can provide the inputs, and
you can provide what you think
it should do, and
then it will report
to you if there's a problem.
And there are existing
tools out there right now
for fuzzing in Go,
but none that are
built into the standard
distribution or part of the Go
toolchain.
And that's something
that we think
is going to be really important
to help just the general user
experience for Go developers
and provide a first class
service with fuzzing.
So I'm really
excited about this,
and I'd love to answer
more questions about it.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Yeah, I'm
also very excited about it,
because, indeed, I used
fuzzing as a security
researcher in the
past, but it always
felt weird that fuzzing is
considered this thing that you
prepare once, you write the
fuzzer, you run it once,
you find your bug
bounties or not,
and then you throw it away.
KATIE HOCKMAN: Yeah.
FILIPPO VALSORDA:
Would you imagine
if unit tests were
something that somebody just
writes once to find
bugs in your program
and then throws them away
after reporting the bugs?
So we do have a question
from Alan about fuzzing.
How long do you think it will
be before the new Go fuzzing
proposal uncovers
bugs in hardware?
KATIE HOCKMAN: I love that
question, so thanks, Alan,
for asking.
I think it's going to depend.
I mean, in my
optimistic view, I am
hoping that people can start
using this tool really,
really soon.
We're kind of on the cusp
of being ready for people
to start beta testing it
in our development branch,
so people should
definitely be looking out
for upcoming
announcements like that.
I'll definitely be posting it on
Twitter so you can watch that.
But at that point,
as soon as people
are ready to start
writing fuzz targets,
they definitely should.
And depending on how good
the fuzzing engine is--
which is what we're
going to be, hopefully,
finding out during the
beta testing phase--
the hope is that it can
find bugs pretty quickly.
What we have right
now is already
using what's called
coverage guidance, meaning
that it can actually
see if there's new code
coverage during
the testing process
and determine if that's an
interesting input or not.
And if it is, then it can focus
on those inputs going forward
and get smarter as it runs.
And so the hope is that as
soon as people start using it,
they're going to be
able to find these bugs.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Excellent.
The next question, from
Jamie, is about something
along the lines of sandboxing.
Jamie asks, are there any plans
to limit dependencies can be?
For example, declaring
that a dependency package
can make network calls or
institute child processes?
It's something that's extremely
interesting to think about,
and it's something that I always
felt like JavaScript could
really do, because
JavaScript already
has a full-fledged
sandboxing story.
Or at least it did until
Spectre happened and realized
that there isn't
really a security
boundary between things that
run inside the same process.
So really, I don't think we
have any plans for Go for that.
Because remember that
in Go, you can do things
like just use unsafe and
access memory directly.
And although there used
to be a safe mode, where
the compiler would try
to disallow things that
look a little too--
that would allow you
to mess with other
dependencies, we never really
trusted the safety
of that, and it's
been removed, if I
remember correctly,
in Go 1.12 or
something like that.
Our recommendation
is very much more
to use instead
process sandboxing.
For example, the Go playground
uses Gvisor to just sandbox
the entire process
and not smaller
units within the process.
Again, Spectre is
really the problem
with that kind of within-process
sandboxing, and too long
to go into details,
but Spectre is
a vulnerability in
the CPUs themselves
and truly a whole
topic of itself.
I will start talking about
Spectre, because I can probably
just go on talking about
Spectre, as Katie knows.
But instead, I'll take the
next question from Guillaume
hopefully.
So how to be sure that the
public Go library that I use
is secure and doesn't contain
backdoors or something else?
I feel like this is something
up your alley, Julie.
JULIE QIU: Yeah, that's
a really great question.
And I think I mentioned
stability is really
one of the things
that you want to look
for when you're thinking
about a third party package.
So today, I would say that
probably the best way to do it
is actually just to treat the
code like it's your own Go
code.
So when you pull the code
down, run the tests that
are part of the repository.
Hopefully, there
are tests there.
If not, that's a pretty
strong signal for you.
And maybe even
write your own tests
to see if you can uncover things
that you're hoping to look for.
But on our end, for
the Go team, one
of the things I'm really
excited about this year
is that on the package
discovery site,
we're building out a
version history timeline
so that when you're
looking at packages,
you can look at what the changes
are from version to version
for a package.
So for example, is the
author deleting identifiers
from version to version?
That's probably a
bad stability signal.
And then, as Filippo
also actually mentioned,
that the security team is
working on a Go [INAUDIBLE]
billing database.
And so the package
discovery site
is going to be one of the
places where we can surface
that information for you.
And so when you go
and look at a package
and it has a security
vulnerability at the most
recent version, there will be
a little piece of information
there to say, just
so you know, this
has a security vulnerability.
Be careful when you're
using this package.
So I'm excited for that
to come out this year.
FILIPPO VALSORDA:
I also feel like it
goes back to what you were
talking about with social proof
and popularity.
Because really,
using software always
involves a trust relationship.
We try to do our best to make
tools to assess the trust
relationship and to minimize
it, but the trust relationship
is fundamentally there.
And something that I think makes
the Go ecosystem much better
suited than others to handle
the trust relationship
is that there's a
culture of limiting
how many dependencies you have.
So there isn't a silver
bullet to make sure
that there aren't backdoors
in your dependency,
but the fewer
dependencies you have,
the fewer liabilities you have.
Now, we have another question
about fuzzing from Stephen.
Will there be a
way to seed fuzzing
or trace the seed for a fuzz
so that errors can be repeated?
So how will I know how to
repeat the failing tests?
KATIE HOCKMAN: Yeah,
so there's two ways
to interpret that question, so
I guess I could answer both.
As far as knowing
whether or not--
so I guess the first part of the
question is, if, in this flow,
fuzzing generates an input
that causes a crasher,
how do we know that that
crasher is actually fixed,
and how can we run that
crasher again in the future
and check it into our
repository as a unit test?
What's really cool
about this UX,
basically, was a very
intentional choice
to try to do this by
default for the user.
So if you were to
run go test -fuzz
and then specify your
target, and it'll run.
And then, if it finds a crash,
it'll actually print out hey,
we found a crash.
We wrote it to
test data for you,
and here's the name of the file.
And to run it again,
that specific C
corpus in the [INAUDIBLE],,
you could actually just
run go test -run fuzz
whatever in that file,
or you can just run go test,
and they'll just include
that as a normal unit test.
So basically, it
can go from fuzzing
to just being a unit
test without you
needing to do anything at all.
And I think that that's a
really important part of the UX.
And if you were to
interpret the question,
instead of actually running it
the same way every single time
for debugging, there
is actually a way
to do that, too, that we're
looking into where you actually
provide the seed for randomness.
But that's probably
not something
that most people
would benefit from.
That's more just for debugging
the actual fuzzing engine.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: I
played with the flow
that Katie is describing,
and I was extremely happy,
because the fuzzer
finds something,
and usually, we
go to fuzzers, we
have to then write
more code to try
to run the fuzzer input into
your program to figure out
how that happened.
As you said, with this,
you just run more tests,
and it fails again.
And then you, try fixing
it, and you run more tests,
and it fails again--
let's be honest.
And then you keep
doing this a few times,
and eventually, the test
passes, and you know that works,
and you did not write one
more line of filler code
or boilerplate.
So yes, I'm extremely
excited for this.
Now, a question from Peter.
Rebecca, I think this one is
definitely for you, and is,
what is the best IDE for
secure code development?
If you like more than
what's the best one,
we can talk about what
they have in common,
too, because I know that there
isn't that much difference
in what runs underneath, right?
REBECCA STAMBLER: Yeah.
So basically, the two
most popular editors
I'd use for Go development
are VSCode and GoLand.
And GoLand is a JetBrains
IDE, so I won't really
be able to speak to that.
But I can speak to VSCode,
and Vim, and Emacs,
and all the other editors
that the Go team does support.
And so as I
mentioned earlier, we
have gopls, which
is the back end that
provides IDE-like features
for all of these editors.
And it has all the same
features across the board.
And so linters that are
available through gopls
are available in VS
and all the same.
But since VSCode is the
most popular editor,
the Go team also supports the
VSCode plugin for Go directly.
And it does have a few
additional features
that community members built
in before the Go team took
ownership of it, so it has a
little bit more linters that
are just built in by default.
Things like GoLang [INAUDIBLE]
are available directly
in VSCode Go plugin.
So that can be useful
and help with security,
but in general, VSCode
has a few features
that are really nice for
security as well as as that.
Right now, they're doing
something called Secure--
or, Trusted Workspaces,
which basically
means that you can indicate
that you trust a workspace.
And that will allow you to run
arbitrary commands in there.
And we've just been, in
general, about a lot of the Go
extensions.
They run the go
command under the hood.
And so we've been
a bit more careful
lately about making sure that
we check that the workspace is
trusted before we do that.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Anybody
paying attention to the security
updates might have noticed
that that's actually
something that's fairly hard.
In Go, we have
this security model
where we consider looking at
the code and building code,
not the same as running it.
Other ecosystems just
don't have the distinction,
and that's a design decision.
But in Go, we guarantee that
downloading a dependency,
building it, and
opening it in VSCode Go
is not going to
execute code from it.
And that's something
that we really
like for triaging
vulnerable code,
because [INAUDIBLE] we can open
random code from the internet
without being worried about that
code trying to run something
in the background on us.
Now, we have another question
that we got before the session
that I feel like
dovetails well on that.
Does Go have a debugger, and
what are upcoming new features
for debugging?
REBECCA STAMBLER:
Yeah, absolutely.
So Go has a debugger
called Delve,
and it's had it for a long time,
though I know a lot of people
often don't actually--
they may not be aware
that Go has a debugger.
But you can access
it through any of--
there are plug-ins, basically,
for all these editors,
like VSCode and et cetera.
But there's a lot of new
stuff coming in this area.
So actually, the way that
gopls works, the IDE back end,
is that basically, it speaks the
language server protocol, which
basically, all
editors can speak it,
and the language server
provides these features.
And that's how they communicate.
So there's a very similar
thing for debuggers, actually.
It's called DAP, which is
Debug Adapter Protocol.
And so Delve is getting--
basically, one big thing
that the tools team is doing
is working on adding
DAP natively to Delve.
So basically, this is going
to be a debug implementation
directly in the debugger,
and it's actually--
it's going to be
coming out shortly.
I think it's available right
now in an experimental mode,
but I think it will be
enabled in a preview
version of the extension
by default pretty soon.
And so you can try
that out in VSCode Go.
And what's really nice about
that is it's previously,
this debug adapter had
been written specific
to each editor plug-in, just
like the same thing for the IDE
integrations like gopls solved.
So basically, now,
there's going to be
a Go implementation
of this protocol,
and any editor can
use it as well.
So basically, debugging
should become a lot easier
pretty soon.
FILIPPO VALSORDA:
That's awesome.
I knew about the language
protocol, this Language Support
Protocol, is that right?
What does LSP stand for?
REBECCA STAMBLER:
Language Server Protocol.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Language
Server Protocol, yes.
And I knew about that.
I didn't know that there was an
equivalent one for debugging.
And that sounds great,
because, again, that
was so much deprecated
work between each editor
and IDE having to integrate
with all of the tooling or, even
worse, rebuild all
of the tooling.
So that's excellent.
We have another question
from Stephen about fuzzing.
So will fuzzing
be more than just
type registries with
candidate values per type?
What kind of smarts
are you fuzzing?
And I think Stephen,
he was probably asking
about the mutator, I guess?
What do you think?
KATIE HOCKMAN: Yeah,
I'm actually not
sure what a type registry
is, but I can definitely
talk about which types
would be supported
and having [INAUDIBLE]
work in that way.
So right now, in, basically,
the development branch
that we're working in,
it's just supporting
basic types, like a byte-size
string, an int, a uint,
float, to things like that.
And all those things can
be mutated in the mutator
and spit out new inputs based
on the values in the corpus.
And in the future,
we also want to be
able to support more types,
just generally speaking--
like an int slice, for
example, things like that.
But we also want to
be able to support
struct types in the future.
So that doesn't
necessarily mean we're
going to support every
single struct right away,
but what we can do
at the beginning,
at least, is to just support
structs that basically
have an implementation
of the text
marshalling or binary
marshalling interface.
And so what we can do
is, then, just mutate
the bytes under the
hood, and then just
unmarshall it back
into the struct value
before we run it against
the fuzz function.
And that's something we
hope to have as well.
And more details on that, as far
as how it works under the hood
and what kinds of things
are going to be supported,
you can see better on the
design draft that's online.
That's at
golang.org/s/draft-design--
I think it's
draft-fuzzing-design.
Or you can just Google it; it
should come up pretty quickly.
FILIPPO VALSORDA:
I hear this Google
engine works pretty well.
[LAUGHS] Now, we talked about
stability for a second earlier.
What are some
features on pkg.go.dev
that can help me evaluate
if a project is stable?
JULIE QIU: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So on a high level,
on the right-hand side
of every package page, you'll
see this little detail section.
And that will tell you if you're
looking at a stable version
of a package.
And so if the author
is following Go module
conventions, and a package
is expected to be stable once
it's been tagged with a
v1.0 or higher release.
And then, additionally,
if an author
decides to track
their package version
or the entire module
has been deprecated,
you'll see a bright
yellow banner
across the site that
tells you, you probably
don't want to use this package.
We also have some
features on our roadmap
that are going to help
developers evaluate stability.
So I mentioned earlier about
showing more about the package
API history from
version to version
so that viewers can see if the
package API is going to change
across different versions.
We're also planning
to surface information
from the Go
Vulnerability Database,
and lastly, also,
more information
about whether or not
specific identifiers
are deprecated within
the API itself.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: And
we got another question
that I feel like is
paired with this one.
Why do Go modules require
SemVer, semantic versioning?
Because you mentioned
V0, V1, and maybe
you can say a little more about
what semantic versioning is
and how it plays into APIs?
JULIE QIU: Yeah, definitely.
Semantic versioning is basically
just a convention that is used,
not just in Go, but
specifically with Go modules.
It's a way for the author to be
able to indicate the, I guess,
level of stability that you
can expect from this project.
And so if it's V0,
then it's expected
that the author might be
causing changes in their API.
They might potentially
be deleting an identifier
from version to version.
Effectively, this package
is not stable yet.
And because it's
V0, the author is
following the convention
of indicating to its users,
this is not stable.
Whereas once you
get to V1 or higher,
then something that you
want to be able to do
is make sure that from
version to version,
you're not breaking your users.
So say I'm using a
function foo in 1.5.2.
I don't want to download 1.6,
and then, all of a sudden,
the author deleted
the identifier,
and I can't use it anymore.
And that's also why
Go has this convention
of using deprecations and
adding a deprecated comment when
an author doesn't want to
use an identifier anymore.
But it should still
be there in case
a user was depending on that
in the previous version.
And I think the
last piece of this
is really just major versions.
And so if you have a change
between V1 and V2 and V3,
it's expected that it's possible
to have breaking changes
between different
major versions .
And so Go actually
has semantic import
versioning so that the import
path changes to indicate this
to users as well.
FILIPPO VALSORDA:
Yeah, the point
about multiple
major versions is, I
think, something that
comes in very handy
when you end up depending
on something that depends--
on two things that depend on
two different major versions
of the same thing.
This is usually called
the diamond problem,
and in Go, that problem
is just solved by the fact
that you can have two
different major versions
of the same module
in the same build.
And if they don't have
the same major version,
then they need to be compatible.
And if they're
compatible, you can just
use the most recent version.
So if two things
depend on V1, we'll
just pick the newest version.
And if a thing depends
on V1 and one on V2,
we'll just have
them both available.
That's just one of the
design bits of modules
that I always really liked.
And you also answered part
of one of the questions
that we got earlier that is
about the crypto libraries,
which is, how often you have
to deprecate older crypto
libraries, and do these
deprecations break
older versions of Go?
So there are two places where
we have crypto libraries,
and for context, Go comes with
a complete set of cryptography
libraries, including things
like TLS, and encryption,
and signatures.
And we do deprecations-- we
did a bunch of deprecations
in the last few years, partially
because the libraries are
almost 10 years old,
and we want to make sure
that anything that you
find in these libraries
is something that
you would want to use
and that is modern
enough that this is not
going to be a [INAUDIBLE].
So we do deprecations,
but deprecations are just
surfaced to tooling.
They will just, for
example, show up
in your editor
saying, hey, you're
using this thing
that is deprecated.
And here's some text that
explains the deprecation,
and here's what you
can use instead.
And they absolutely
never break in the code,
whether they are in
the standard library,
or in the GoLang or
[INAUDIBLE] repository.
Because more of them follow
the Go backwards compatibility
promise, so make
sure that they're
always backwards compatible.
So we use deprecation instead
to communicate about things
that we kind of
wish weren't there,
but we're going to keep
them there because we
don't want to break anybody.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so our time is,
I think, running out.
So we have one last
question, which
I think everybody can answer.
What is one thing you would
recommend checking out for Go?
Katie, do you want to start?
KATIE HOCKMAN:
Yeah, so one thing
I think that's worth
checking out is go.dev.
This is something that
Julie could also, probably,
care a lot about.
But go.dev is going to be
a new way to explore Go.
In the past, everyone went to
golang.org to read about it,
but go.dev has a
lot of cool things
like case studies
and information about
how it can be used.
And so if you're an
enterprise and you
want to look into
adding Go, that's
a really good place to start.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Julie?
JULIE QIU: Yes, go.dev is very
near and dear to my heart,
so I hope that
everyone checks it out.
But I think one of the
things that I really
loved about building
the Go Package Discovery
site is actually
just discovering
some really amazing packages
for my development workflow.
And some that we
use all the time
is Static Check, which runs
static analysis on your code.
And it's caught tons of bugs and
made improvements to my code.
Unparam has helped me catch
a ton of unused functional
parameters and
results in my code.
Misspell has helped me catch
a lot of commonly misspelled
English words.
And so those are
some packages that I
really love, and use all time,
and recommend checking out.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Yeah,
those are excellent.
Rebecca?
REBECCA STAMBLER:
Yeah, for sure,
Static Check is
available in your editor.
So definitely use that.
But I would recommend checking
out the Go Playground, which
is a sandbox where you can
basically play with Go code
without having to have
anything on your computer.
And you can have multiple files.
You can use third party
dependencies in it.
It's really awesome.
It's a really quick way
to just write something,
if you want, as just
like a scratch project.
FILIPPO VALSORDA: Wonderful.
So on my side, something that
I used just a couple of days
ago is this package
called errgroup
that you can find
in the golang.org
at sync module, which allows
you to run in parallel
a number of Go [INAUDIBLE].
And just when one of them
hits an error, all of them
get canceled, and the error
gets returned at the end.
I find that just such a nice
way to build parallelization
into the programs.
Now, this has been
fun, and we didn't
get to all of the
questions, but we will
try to answer them in the Dory.
And if anybody has
any other questions,
you can always reach the Go
community and the Go team
on the golangnuts--
like in peanuts--
mailing list and on
the Go First Slack.
Thank you, everyone, and have
a great rest of the conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]